our final speaker of the day is peter
schweitzer who serves as president of
the government accountability institute
and i hasten to add he's for
accountability
not against it
he is also a partner in oval office
writers a speech writing and
communications firm in 2008 and 2009 he
was a consultant to the office of
presidential speech writing in the white
house
he has also served as a member of the
ultra terrorism study group at sandia
national laboratories he makes frequent
appearances on radio and television and
he writes for many publications
including foreign affairs in the wall
street journal
he's also a prolific author of many
books academic and popular
including the reagan presidency
assessing the man and his legacy
and his most recent book which caused
quite a stir
when it appeared is clinton cash the
untold story of how and why foreign
governments and businesses helped make
bill and hillary rich
i thought progressives were opposed to
the one percent
for our final lecture of this hillsdale
college national leadership seminar on
the topic money and politics please
welcome peter schweitzer
thank you for that warm introduction
it's great to be here uh and to be
associated with such a fine institution
as hillsdale college
now back in 2011 something happened that
really nobody paid attention to
you see back in 2011 washington dc
passed silicon valley
to take the crown as the city in america
with the highest per capita income
washington dc if you look at the 10
wealthiest counties in the united states
seven of those are counties that border
our nation's capital
washington dc a couple years ago passed
napa valley california for the
consumption of fine wines
and to tell you how bad it is let me
give you an illustration from something
i did with fox news a couple years ago
we did a special called boom town where
we went around and looked at the economy
in washington dc and how it was booming
and one of the things we did in that
program is we went and actually
interviewed a car salesman who worked
for a ferrari of washington d.c
and you can find this on youtube by the
way this interview and we talked to him
we said how is business he says business
is great we are selling lots of cars
but he said there's a problem ferrari of
north america is upset with us
and i said wait a minute how can ferrari
of north america be upset with you
you're selling so many cars he says well
here's the problem
when people buy ferraris in south beach
in florida
they finance the purchase
when they buy them in ferrari of beverly
hills they finance the purchase and
ferrari of north america likes that when
they buy ferraris in washington dc
they pay cash
now we have come to the state in america
where i continue the size and growth in
government is not just a function of
liberal ideology it's a function of
profitability here's the basic problem
big obtrusive government
is not only a dream for ideological
liberals it also creates potential
opportunities for self-enrichment and i
want to talk to you today about some of
the techniques they use
then i want to talk to you about the
special case what i would contend is the
very special case of the clintons and
how they threaten to undermine
the united states the sovereignty of the
country the integrity of our political
process in a way that no other political
family couple or candidate has in
american history
first of all let's talk a little bit
about self-enrichment anybody here been
to washington dc recently
if you've been to washington dc recently
you will find that there are lots of
construction trains that the nicest
restaurants in town are absolutely
booked on a wednesday night it's hard to
get in washington dc is booming and part
of that is the size and scope of
governments you've just got more
government employees you've got more
government contractors but you have an
additional problem and that is that big
government creates opportunity for
making lots of money and let me just
give you a couple of examples
first one here anybody involved in
finance or corporate finance that has
worked in that field
you all know and i'm sure everybody else
in this crowd knows that insider trading
on the stock market is illegal right if
you work for general electric and you
know in advance that the quarterly
financials are coming out and ge is
going to do very very well
uh you know you better not buy ge stock
in advance because if you do that on
inside information or you share that
information with somebody that does that
you are probably going to go to jail
but there's a loophole particularly for
those in washington dc
if you are a u.s senator if you are a
government bureaucrat
and the government your agency or your
senatorial committee is going to make a
decision
that is going to affect dramatically the
health of a major u.s company you as a
senator are free to buy or sell stock in
that company it is not technically
illegal for you to do so how do we know
they're doing it well let me give you uh
some statistics from a study that was
done a couple of years ago in something
called the journal of quantitative
economics
now if you are looking to fall asleep at
night and you're having trouble i
suggest you subscribe to the journal of
quantitative economics because i know
next to nothing about math but here's
what they did in this study and it's
absolutely fascinating they looked at
how how well people did in their stock
market investing and what they found is
that the average american which would
certainly include me actually tends to
underperform the market in their stock
picks average american usually doesn't
do very well
the average corporate executive that's
trading their own company's stock
they tend to beat the market by about
five percent a year so they actually do
pretty well they understand the industry
they understand their company hedge
funds the guys that not too far from
here get paid very large fees tend to
beat the market averages by seven
percent a year
now here's what the study gets
interesting
united states senators
they tend to beat the market by 12
percent a year
so my question for you fine audience is
are our u.s senators just simply more
brilliant than we give them credit for
that these guys should all be running
hedge funds or is something else going
on and i would contend to you that
something else is going on and there's
ample evidence that it's going on
but it's not just a function of senators
or elected officials trading stocks on
the stock market and winning big there
is a growing industry in washington
that's even more profitable than
lobbying or government relations and
that's something called political
intelligence
now for some of you of course political
intelligence you would consider that an
oxymoron but political intelligence
is very simply this
it's usually an ex-politician or an
ex-congressional staffer they get paid
by hedge funds to do what to get
information on what the government's
going to do
so if there is a bill in the senate
that's going to be beneficial to timber
prices
you as a political intelligence
operative would call your former
colleagues and say hey is this bill
going to pass is it going to pass
without amendment you would share that
information with the hedge fund which
would trade on that information or for
example if medicare is going to change
reimbursement rates on certain
procedures that's going to have a
dramatic effect on the profitability of
certain health care companies that's
information that traders want to know
and so political intelligence is
creating opportunities for what is
creating opportunities for insides to
profit from the complexity
and the difficulty of operating in
washington dc but let me give you a
second example of how the size and
growth of government has become
enormously profitable unfortunately and
i think is one of the things that's
fueling the complexity of the laws that
we have
everybody here is is probably uh uh
familiar with uh dodd-frank right this
was the big financial reform that was
supposed to clean up wall street it was
supposed to create rules for
big wall street firms to make sure that
we don't have happen what happened in
2008. now the last time this kind of
overhaul took place was back in the
1930s under fdr and when they
reconfigured the entire financial system
and the regulatory structure in the
1930s the bill was what 36 pages long
it was pretty easy to understand pretty
easy to comprehend well along comes
dodd-frank dodd-frank is not 36 pages
long it's not 3 600 pages long it's more
like eight to ten thousand pages long
depending on how you calculate the
information in it and everybody from
warren buffett to the smartest lawyers
on wall street will tell you
this law can send people to jail and we
have absolutely no idea what these rules
actually mean
now it'd be very easy to dismiss this
and say well it just shows that you know
the people who wrote the legislation are
incompetent
that um you know government is run amok
and i would continue that's part of it
but you also need to consider the fact
that the rules were written that way for
a reason
why write complex difficult rules that
specialists can't
understand
because if you're the person that wrote
the rule
you can quit your job and get hired as a
consultant
and this is precisely what happened with
dodd-frank so the top advisors to for
senator dodd of connecticut who
co-sponsored the bill
after the bill passed they quit their
jobs and they said you know if you want
to understand what this law means you
can pay me a flat fee of 100 000 and i
will tell you precisely what these rules
mean
the equivalent is basically this it's as
if they wrote this bill in an ancient
language like sanskrit
and said you need to comply with this
real law and if you don't you can go to
jail
if you're somebody on wall street
wouldn't you pay somebody a hundred
thousand dollars to translate it from
sanskrit of course you would and that's
precisely what is fueling the growing
complexity and the growing difficulty of
understanding and interpreting the rules
that are being created in washington dc
again what's happening in washington and
the size and scope of government is not
just philosophical or ideological it is
profit-minded
well i've talked a little bit about the
side of self-enrichment that's happening
in washington dc let me talk about
another aspect of money in politics and
that is looking at the basic question of
the amount of money that is flowing into
political campaigns it's really
unprecedented and you will find that
a lot of people when they discuss this
issue may have
different ideas of what should be done
but i haven't found anybody who is
not a little bit concerned by the fact
that presidential campaigns now often
take a billion dollars in order to
execute donald trump is changing that or
seems to be changing that in a little
bit by sheer will of force
he's spending very little of his own
money and seems to be doing well in the
polls but time will tell when we get to
a general election if you still don't
have to have hundreds of millions of
dollars at hand to run for president of
the united states now what is the way in
which we have always thought about money
in politics it's what i would call the
mr smith goes to washington paradigm
anybody here remember the great jimmy
stewart movie mr smith goes to
washington
great movie jimmy stewart is appointed
to the senate he's earnest he's hard
working he wants to do the honest thing
and yet there are these outside
corporate entities that are trying to
corrupt him and this has been the
paradigm that we have operated under for
the last 40 years that the problem is
not the political class in washington
the problem is corporate types and if we
could just protect uh these wonderful
young vessels that are running for
political office from outside entities
we won't have a problem with corruption
in other words the paradigm is one of
bribery politicians get tempted by
outside corrupting forces they can't
help it and they end up basically going
along with those corruptive forces well
that certainly does happen but i would
contend with you a much larger problem
is what i call the extortion paradigm
and what is the extortion paradigm
think about it in terms of economics if
you are a politician and you know that
you need to raise money for
election or re-election
and also you've got political action
committees that you want to fund and you
can use by the way some of those pac
dollars to subsidize your lifestyle so
it can also make your quality of life
better what do you need to do as a
politician in that kind of environment
you need to create a demand for your
services right
i mean nobody's going to throw money at
you because they like you some people
will in a lot of cases you have to drum
up support now there are individuals
there are lots of individuals who give
to candidates out of the pure motive of
simply wanting to support somebody they
like to get elected in office and there
are those individuals who uh just
basically give to politicians uh because
they think it's their civic duty to do
so but most surveys show that over 50
percent
of people operating in a corporate
environment don't contribute because
they want to they contribute because
they feel like they have to
58 in one survey of corporate executives
said the reason they gave political
contributions is because they felt if
they didn't bad things were going to
happen to them and this is precisely
where the political class wants things
so my contention to you would be this
the problem for money in politics is not
so much that you've got all these
outside entities wanting to influence
politicians and corrupt the process
what you've got are politicians who are
creating a demand for their services by
creating circumstances that force or
compel outside entities to make
contributions let me give you a couple
of examples
first one there's something in
washington dc that is called a milker
bill anybody here heard of a milker bill
okay a milker bill
is something that has nothing to do with
the dairy industry it has nothing to do
with cows a milker bill is what it
implies it is a bill that is introduced
to milk campaign contributions
from
either labor unions or from corporate
entities and so how does a milker bill
work well if i'm a committee chairman or
a powerful senator i introduce a bill
best thing to do is a special tax on a
key industry so i introduce a bill to
the high tech industry saying you know i
think google and microsoft and the
high-tech sector needs to pay a special
tax a certax because they're making too
much money so i introduced that bill
with great fanfare
what's going to happen
there's going to be a rush of lobbyists
coming to my office saying wait a second
why does senator schweitzer want there
to be a special cert tax or tax placed
on the high-tech sector and they're
going to make all kinds of policy
arguments about why it's a bad idea it's
going to hurt jobs it's going to hurt
competitiveness etc etc but that assumes
that i'm actually interested in the
policy implications if i've introduced a
milk or bill i'm not interested in the
policy implications i'm interested in
money so after they make their arguments
i'm going to say that's very interesting
thank you i'm going to have to think
about it
well the lobbyists quickly get the
message the way to get me to think about
it
is to number one maybe hire a family
member as a lobbyist a lot of people
don't realize one out of three u.s
senators today sitting u.s senators has
an immediate family member that's a
spouse or a son or daughter who is a
registered lobbyist
and there are numerous examples to show
how widespread this is and how
ridiculous it is but that's the first
thing i'm going to hope that they're
going to do and that is hire maybe my
son or my daughter or a relative as a
lobbyist for their entity the second
thing i'm going to ask them to do is to
raise money for me and if they raise
enough money to me and they show the
commitment to me i will withdraw the
bill from introduction but here's the
great thing about a milker bill
i can reintroduce it again next year
and we can go through the same thing
again i can get the same contributions i
can create the revenue opportunities for
my family members and this system will
work quite well
now the only thing better than a milker
bill is a double milker bill
and what is a double milker bill that's
when you introduce a piece of
legislation that pits two wealthy
industries against each other and then
you let the arms race begin
and so let me give you a real world
example of this in 2011 there was a bill
introduced called sopa the stop online
piracy act
now this was a bill that said that
online companies like google and
microsoft needed to be held into account
if people online were selling
counterfeit
merchandise or if they were selling
illegally
downloaded music or movies that that
were pirated
now you know this may sound like a great
idea and in theory in practice imagine
how is google going to police who shows
up on their google searches but again
logic here is not the point what sopa
did when it was introduced was it did
two things number one the recording
industry in hollywood loved it
and the high-tech industry google and
microsoft fell into an absolute panic
and so what happened the arms race began
president obama in particularly handled
this masterfully because you know what
he did
at the beginning of the introduction of
this bill the white house put the took
the position
we're going to think about it
we're not sure whether we support this
or not we're going to think about it and
that's a great place to be when there's
a double milker bill in play
and that brings me to the question of
the high-tech industry in itself when it
comes to this whole model of extortion
and i think is a great example of of how
political fundraising and lobbying has
become so extortive
back in the 1990s the high-tech industry
microsoft apple and the others barely at
all had a presence in washington dc they
didn't make many campaign contributions
if they if they did it was not an
organized exec
action by executives it was something
that individual employees made at their
own behest and they didn't even really
have a lobbying presence microsoft had
somebody working in suburban maryland
that was selling software to the
government that occasionally when needed
would go and meet with people on capitol
hill
then in 1998 the justice department said
we might have to break up microsoft as a
monopoly
now when this happened forget the legal
arguments for a second that changed
everything and it created an extortive
environment to where the high-tech
industry which essentially would prefer
to be left alone by washington dc is
today the largest contributor to
political campaigns in washington and
that is not by design there are numerous
quotes over the years from republicans
and democrats that said
we need to let the high-tech industry
know that they need us
and that they need to support us and
they found a way to do that through
these extortive practices
now
how do you fix and deal with these
issues and these problems i would
continue it's not easy but let me
propose a couple of general suggestions
before i get to the question of the
clintons and then we can open it up for
questions first of all on the issue of
money flowing into politics i happen to
believe that people have a first
amendment right
to
express their political views so if i am
a staunch environmentalist or i believe
in a strong national defense and i want
to run political advertisements that
don't necessarily endorse a campaign but
says we need leaders who support the
environment or leaders who want a strong
national defense i believe you have a
first amendment right to do so i also
believe that you have a right to make
contributions to political candidates
and i think it's good that there are
some limits or caps on those like we
have today
but here's the problem with the way the
current system operates anybody here
operate in in finance or the insurance
business or have familiarity in that
area
anybody that's operated in that space
will tell you when you look at the
marketplace in insurance or finance
like any marketplace you have buyers and
sellers of insurance products
the vast bulk of the regulatory
restrictions are on who
the sellers
the people that are selling insurance
projects the products there are enormous
regulatory burdens that are placed on
them very little placed on the buyers
now let's look at the influence
marketplace in washington dc
you have the buyers of influence which
would be outside entities special
interests corporations labor unions and
you have the sellers of influence which
are the politicians
who gets regulated in this marketplace
the buyers the buyers and that of course
is because the rules are written by the
sellers
i think the way that you deal with this
issue
is you start regulating the sellers of
influence if we believe that there is a
corrupting culture in washington dc or
revolving around the inflow of money we
should put regulatory controls on the
politicians
not on the people who are buying
influence so one of the things i
proposed one of the reforms i proposed
is doing in washington what we already
do in 29 states including the state of
florida where i live
very very simple rule in florida
when the florida legislature is in
session
politicians what
cannot solicit or receive campaign
contributions period
period
now imagine if we took that rule that's
in 29 states and applied it in
washington dc and said members of
congress and senators can't solicit or
receive campaign contributions while
congress is in session
i can tell you one thing we'd have a lot
shorter congressional sessions right
that'd be the first thing that would
happen
but something else i think would happen
too is some of the extortive properties
that operate in the washington culture
would go away because part of the
leverage that they have is the mere fact
that industries or entities are
concerned that congress is going to do
something bad to them and the sort of
damocles that hangs over them is
precisely when congress is in session so
reforms like that i think could have an
enormous effect on these sorts of
behaviors in washington d.c
second reform i would propose and that
relates to issues of corruption we
absolutely have to recognize if we
believe in limited government
that the problem is no longer
philosophical or ideological it is money
driven and until you start changing the
incentive structures in washington dc
you are going to have people that
initially might have advocated for
limited government they suddenly become
champions of larger government because
that's where the money is
i had a congressman who's simply left
public life tell me you know the problem
is in washington when you first get here
it's a cesspool
you stick around for a while and it
starts feeling like a hot tub
it is a corrupting influence so
for example term limits i was not in
favor of term limits before i am now
second of all why not a lifetime ban
on members of congress leaving congress
and becoming lobbyists and why not
prevent immediate family members from
registering as lobbyists as well none of
these reforms are silver bullets but we
absolutely have to break the back of
this profit culture in washington dc
because increasingly
we are a country that has a capital city
that looks more like versailles
and less like the washington dc of the
19th century when it was considered a
diplomatic outpost that no
self-respecting french diplomat would
ever want to be posted to
it's become a great city a wealthy city
at our expense now
why is it that i singled out the
clintons in my recent book clinton cash
and i want to tell you today it is
precisely because they represent a
fundamental
transformation in the way that money is
flowing into politics well how can i say
that don't they have to abide by the
same rules as everyone else
well
yes and no
if there's one consensus point on money
and politics over the last 40 years it's
this
politics is a dirty game
there's money in politics
but by golly it's a dirty game that
ought to be played just by americans we
don't want foreign entities foreign
financiers foreign governments
uh you know foreign oligarchs trying to
manipulate our political leaders and to
show you how strong this consensus point
is back in 2012
two canadians challenge the
constitutionality of federal law federal
law says
foreign nationals cannot contribute to
political campaigns they cannot
contribute to super pacs they cannot
give money to political candidates two
canadians challenged that law saying it
was unconstitutional
supreme court came back
nine to zero
basically saying are you nuts
of course it's constitutional it makes
complete sense now when was the last
time any supreme court decision you
heard of was nine to zero
so there is a consensus in our country
we don't want foreign entities trying to
influence our political process here's
the problem
the clintons have found a way around it
and we have a circumstance today whereby
there is a massive infusion of foreign
money going to the clintons
that is unaccountable for
and that has had a corrupting influence
on the decisions that hillary clinton
made as secretary of state and going
forward i believe would have the same
effect on her as president
uh what are we talking about in terms of
numbers well on the speaking fees we're
talking about 160 million dollars
and when it comes to the clinton
foundation we're talking about two
billion dollars
well you know how does this work what am
i talking about here you're basically
talking about they use two mechanisms
for money to come in to them one is
through the clinton foundation the other
is through so-called speaking fees for
bill clinton let me give you just a
couple of examples of how this process
works
first of all i want to tell you a story
it's a story about four things
it's about hillary clinton
it's about the government of russia
it's about uranium
and it's about 145 million dollars in
cash now this is a story that has two
chapters in my book clinton cash we
shared the findings in the book before
it was published with the new york times
investigative team they went back
confirmed what we found and when the
book came out they actually ran a 4 000
word front page piece confirming the
story that i am now going to tell you
and the story is really quite simple
back in 2005
a canadian financier named frank justra
wanted to get uranium concessions in a
country called kazakhstan which is run
by a very nasty brutal dictator named
nazarbayev
juicer had wanted these concessions for
a long time they were worth about 500
million dollars and he couldn't get them
so he decided to get on his plane and
bring bill clinton with him
why not bring an ex-president right
they'll give you the sort of prestige
that you want they showed up in
kazakhstan and bill clinton went about
publicly in a press conference praising
the leadership of nazarbayev now
nazarbayev has won every election by
90-something percent he throws political
opponents in jail he is a brutal
dictator but you wouldn't know it from
the press conference that bill clinton
gave bill clinton not only praised him
for his enlightened leadership he
actually said that this man should be
the become the head of an international
human rights organization
something that had been rejected by
both the uh bush administration and the
bill clinton's administration in the
1990s
bill clinton praised him and guess what
the next day frank giustra got the
uranium concession
three weeks after that frank giustra
sent a check to the clinton foundation
for more than 30 million dollars
now the story does not end there because
what frank geuster does is he takes that
uranium concession he puts it in a
company called uranium one and he starts
buying uranium assets in the united
states in places like utah and colorado
and texas
when it gets to the point where he has
now purchased about 50 percent
of u.s future uranium production
flash forward to 2009.
somebody is interested in buying uranium
one and they're prepared to pay top
dollar for it but there's a problem
you know who wants to buy uranium one
the russian government
an entity called rossaton with which is
the russian state atomic nuclear agency
rasatam these are the guys that built
the nuclear reactors in iran they do
nuclear technology exchanges with
wonderful people like north korea
these this is the government entity in
russia that controls their nuclear
arsenal and vladimir putin believes that
uranium is a way for russia to exert its
international control and its
international strength
so the russians want to buy uranium one
what's the problem the problem is
uranium is a critical industry and for
that reason it falls under the rubric of
federal regulations that require several
government agencies including the state
department to approve the deal
now
as the russians make this announcement
in 2009 something strange happens
with the uranium one shareholders
uranium one in canada that owns all this
uranium
it's not a very big company but you
suddenly have this massive uprising of
philanthropy
the nine shareholders in this company
decide this would be a great time to
increase their charitable giving and
even better yet they decide this is a
great time to increase their charitable
giving to the clinton foundation
so they pony up
145
million dollars
to the clinton foundation
and lo and behold three months later
what happens
hillary clinton approves the transfer of
u.s uranium assets to the russian
government the canadian financiers make
out well the clintons make out well the
russian government makes that well
the rest of us are all screwed
but that is an example of how the
clinton foundation has operated and in a
way that has led to the self-enrichment
and has led to influence peddling by the
way the individuals involved in uranium
one they couldn't make campaign
contributions to the clinton campaign
they couldn't set up a super pac to help
her candidacy but they could give 145
million dollars to the clinton
foundation let me give you an example
now from the speaking fees in the same
way in which it works now bill clinton
like every president since eisenhower
hit the lecture circuit after he left
the white house and nobody can fault him
for that at least i don't i think
ex-presidents can do that but in the
clinton's case it's a little bit
different because bill clinton left
office as his wife was going into office
first she was an influential u.s senator
then she became secretary of state and
so bill clinton in 2001 was giving paid
speeches he was making about
175.000 speech nice payday
but something strange happens in early
2009
now this is eight years after he's left
office for most people on the lecture
circuit especially if you're a
government official next president your
speaking fees tend to go down over time
right you're not as exciting you don't
have great inside stories to tell
anymore it's just the way that things
kind of work
but in early 2009 something great
happened to bill clinton speaking fees
they went up by about threefold
now what how else happened in january of
2009 anybody remember
that's of course when hillary clinton
became secretary of state now you know
you could perhaps argue that bill became
three times more eloquent
that he was three times smarter and
that's the reason these speaking fees
went up i think it had something to do
with his wife now being at the center of
u.s national security decision making
let me give you just one example of how
this works there's a swedish telecom
company called ericsson
now erickson has this habit of selling
telecom equipment to oppressive
governments around the world
they sell telecom equipments to belarus
they sell them to venezuela and of
course most notoriously they sell it to
the government of iran and this was a
problem
for them first with the bush
administration and then increasingly
with hillary clinton's state department
and as i point out in the book there are
lots of state department cables where we
are browbeating the swedish foreign
minister telling them you need to get
erickson in line they need to stop
selling this kind of equipment to the
government of iran there's movement on
capitol hill to ban the sale of any
telecom equipment to
the government of iran and to basically
force ericsson's hand there is mounting
pressure
as this company is named in state
department reports and all evidence
points to aggressive action taken by the
federal government against erickson
well erickson thought at this time it
might be a great idea to pay bill
clinton for a speech
now they had never paid bill clinton for
a speech before he'd been on the lecture
circuit for 10 years they had never paid
for a speaking fee before but they
decided this would be a great time to do
it and you know if you're going to do it
you might as well go in big
so they paid him 750 000 for a 20-minute
speech
that's the most that bill clinton has
ever been paid for a single speech
before by ericsson bill clinton gave a
speech and something happened nine days
later
nine days later the state department
hillary state department issued a
statement under her name which said we
are not going to take action to restrict
the conduct of companies like ericsson
we are going to count on them to quote
unquote police themselves
which is exactly what ericsson wanted
now
some people might say you look at these
examples the clintons know a lot of
people they're very busy these are
probably just coincidences the problem
is that this pattern of behavior occurs
over and over and over again
and you are left to either one of two
conclusions
first of all
maybe the clintons operate in a parallel
universe
that is dominated by coincidence in a
way that none of us could imagine
or
or
the old adage of politics is right
follow the money
and when you follow the money with the
clintons what you end up with is a
circumstance
of rampant corruption and
self-enrichment and where does that
leave us that leaves us simply with the
case that this is not only about the
clintons it's about the future of the
country because if something is not done
by the apparatus that the clintons have
set up to take in this large influx of
foreign money this is going to become
the wave of the future
and don't
be surprised if five years from now if
nothing is done about this that we don't
have a secretary of defense
whose spouse hits the lecture circuit
giving high paid speeds uh speeches to
foreign entities and they set up a
family foundation to take donations from
foreign entities that have matters
before the pentagon because that is
precisely what the clintons have done
and that is what the clintons say that
they are going to continue to do if she
becomes president of the united states
so with that i want to say thank you and
i'd love to get any questions or
comments that you might have
yes i think i think there's some
microphones out go ahead i have a yeah
first of all a comment um i like the
milka principle was it or the and the
double milker principle my favorite
example of that is the
farm industry in terms of ethanol versus
the petroleum industry how much ethanol
will congress mandate to be placed in a
gallon of gasoline one benefits the
other loses there's the competition and
hence the price for corruption
um
i have to say though with all due
respect that your modest proposals for
report reform
will not work campaign finance reform
has been around since about to 1906 the
a series of bills there's always a way
around it you shorten congress you let
you explaining the time in which they're
going to pay in advance for what the
next session is going to give them
i would just like to suggest that there
is a solution a very radical one perhaps
but something that maybe america is
ready to embrace
and that is the idea that to take the
money out of politics you must take the
power to enrich special interests away
from the politicians away from congress
what i propose is
a movement to send an army of mr smith's
to washington with the priority of
cutting programs and closing agencies
preferably to make government what it
was originally meant to be a protector
not a provider
no i love the sentiment and i think
you're right i think the problem is that
you've got to at least institute some
structural reforms it's not a question
of getting quote unquote good people
into politics don't get me wrong there
are good people in politics and i want
good people running but the system is
corrupting
and my worldview and my faith tells me
that you know people get tempted people
are corrupted you give them power you
give them the ability to make money they
will resist they will resist they will
resist and some some of them will
continue to resist but a lot of them
eventually will give in and succumb
so i agree with you that that there is
no silver bullet
but i do think that the way reform is
going to work is it's going to be you
know death by a thousand cuts and you've
got to have a series of reforms but
we've got to make this a priority and
here's the problem right now
and both sides of the aisle do this
the mindset is basically yeah my guy may
be corrupt but he's my guy and their
guy's a lot worse
uh and both sides do that and my problem
is look what you have in washington dc
is a permanent political class
you know i'm not suggesting that there
aren't partisan differences between
republicans and democrats but when it
comes to these issues
there ain't a whole lot of difference
and and here's the analogy i would use
with you
i grew up in seattle washington and when
i was 12 years old i turned on channel
13 which was a a small independent
channel and i discovered the wonderful
world of professional wrestling
and these were large men and spandex
outfits that were hitting each other
with chairs throwing each other out of
the ring and i thought as a 13 year old
this is awesome
now i hate to break it to you guys
some of you guys
but it's all fake
it's all fake and and here's the thing
when you watch it you think these guys
hate each other i mean they are pounding
each other they are pulling hair they
are flinging them out of the ring they
hate each other they don't eat each
other they're business partners
and in washington dc there's a lot of
that
there's a lot of that they want to
create the impression that they are
throwing each other out of the ring that
they hate each other but they are
business partners at some realm and that
is that neither political party their
establishments are interested in any
kind of these reforms because they've
got it good
you've got lobbying firms now where
republicans and democrats are going to
business together so it's now bipartisan
lobbying because that way they can cover
both sides
so you know my point would be there is
no silver bullet but we've got to make
this a priority and i argue for both
sides to have zero tolerance if the
person on your side is enriching
themselves let's not make excuses
nobody's irreplaceable we can find
somebody better to get in that position
to do better
yes ma'am
sorry
um i have to say again i'm alice labrie
and i'm former
u.s department of state foreign service
i'm also a republican in harlem
do you have a family
i do
okay
sir i think you better be careful about
your safety
thank you
thank you we do we do take precautions
in that way but i thank you i appreciate
that very much
yes
let him get the mic from here so
everybody can hear it yeah
uh yeah i always thought that just a
reinstatement of glass-steagall would
have been sufficient right so why did
they do dodd-frank and i like your idea
about the fact that it was a full
employment bill for the people who wrote
it
but what about the crony capitalistic
aspect where they these companies these
bills are written to the advantage of
big banks like bank america and so forth
to the extreme disadvantages of the
small local banks who don't have the
staff to comply with them yes now that
that's a great point one of the biggest
myths in american politics is that big
business hates regulation big business
loves regulation why because they can
they can comply much easier than their
smaller competitors so big business and
big governments are not at each other's
throats and again i think there's a
certain professional wrestling aspect
there people in washington need to say
that they're taking on the big banks in
wall street and that they're taking on
the big oil companies when it actually
comes to the implementation of reforms
or changes they are done in such a
manner where they're done to the
detriment of weaker competitors who
cannot comply uh and that is an absolute
reality so you're right this is this is
multi-layered and i think one of the
biggest arguments that the things that
we can try to do to get our neighbors is
to get them to start thinking about
government not as a philosophical
competition between liberals and
conservatives although that that is
important but to think of it in business
terms think of it in business terms is a
business model there are people that are
making decisions in washington not based
on whether this conforms with the
constitution or whether this is
something my progressive progressive
views would embrace they think of in
terms of how do i monetize this so i
think you're you're absolutely right
yes sir over here
two uh two questions uh
one what about the idea of uh raising uh
salaries for uh legislators to very
substantial amounts of money so there's
you know there's just less incentive and
secondly
what what's wrong with uh allowing
people to give how much however much
money they want to their candidate
you know it's a free country it's your
money what why not uh allow it that
would help raise money for campaigns and
you know let individuals give whatever
they want
uh you know two two uh good questions um
i think that um on the issue of um
campaign contributions
here's part of the problem
the smart people in washington dc have
figured out a way to use campaign
contributions and more specifically
donations to
political action committees to subsidize
their own lifestyles
so when you are making a campaign
contribution to a so-called leadership
pack
and and pretty much you know you look at
the term leadership pack and you assume
it's only the leaders that have them
they're actually people that are running
for congress who haven't been elected
yet who create leadership packs and what
does the leadership pac say it allows
you to take in ten thousand dollars a
year from a contributor and unlike a
campaign committee or unlike a super pac
there are really basically no
restrictions on how that money spent
we did a story i think 2013 with 60
minutes on this and you would be amazed
at the things that they use this for
they use them to uh to buy sporting
events tickets they you know anybody
here college football fan members of
congress use the leadership pac money to
take the family to the to the uh you
know college football championship they
get box seats at yankee games they use
it for a private limousine service they
use it for babysitter service they take
the family to edinboro scotland as a
quote unquote fact-finding mission so
the problem is is that campaign
contributions are not just about helping
get somebody elected they're now about
subsidizing somebody's lifestyle and by
the way
it's tax-free
right
politician doesn't pay taxes on the
leadership pac money so if i use it to
hire a babysitter that's not coming from
tax dollars that's coming from somebody
else's money so i understand the
theoretical argument that people have a
first amendment right to contribute as
much as they want to and and if it's
disclosed what's wrong with it the
problem is is that it's not a system
that is just about electing people it's
a system about self enrichment and if
somebody could plunk down a million
dollars into a congressman's uh
leadership pack
i mean imagine the kind of lifestyle
that they would exist as far as salaries
are concerned i think it's an intriguing
idea
i think you know you may not have heard
it there but i heard the murmuring in
the room i don't think there's an
appetite for paying these guys more
and and i think that is a problem i also
think by the way that it's not something
that is drawn out of um
you know poverty or a lack of money i
think it's a mindset i think it's a
mindset and the analogy i would use is
that um you know corruption is not just
about people that wish they had more
money and they just don't have enough
look at insider trading on wall street i
mean some of the biggest indictments
have been to people worth hundreds of
millions of dollars
um and i think it's the same thing in
washington dc i think it's a attitude
and a mindset of entitlement that
motivates them not so much that you know
they're scraping by on on on money and
it's hard for them to uh to get by so
but great questions
yes sir yes you did a great job of
talking about elected officials and
you've of course described angela
codovia's country class versus ruling
class did you would you care to comment
about the
the non-elected officials the staffers
and the administrative state the epa and
people like that
oh absolutely i mean the same
the same principles i talked about
complexity is good simplicity is bad
rules that have real teeth that can end
somebody in jail but are difficult to
understand and comply with
this is the bread and butter of the
environmental consulting industry and if
you look at the environmental consulting
industry and here's how to research this
by the way go on the websites
of environmental consulting firms and by
the way do the same thing for financial
regulatory consultants it's amazing what
you'll find you will find them making
statements like bill joined the firm in
2013 in 2012 he wrote the such and such
bill that is essential for you to
understand i mean they're that blatant
about it so you're quite right this is
not just about congressional staffers
it's about bureaucrats in the epa and
other rule makers who can create complex
rules that are hard for people to
understand and then they can quit their
jobs and start consulting consulting
firms and to me this is a huge problem
you elect a republican you
put republicans in the senate in the
house their anti-regulation this problem
is not going to go away because
ultimately it's hard to pay attention to
all the rules that are being written
what you have to do is change the
incentive structure and one of the
things that i would call for is if you
work for for the epa or you involved in
rulemaking you cannot do consulting in
that area for five years a lot of people
would say that's draconian but i don't
know how else you can try to create
disincentives for this kind of behavior
to take place but i think it absolutely
has to be done yes sir
okay
in your book
i was very interested by how the
clintons
had
moments where they suddenly saw things
differently
okay
and one you mentioned was
non-proliferation
and
india could you just tell the group a
little bit about that
sure um so you know the clintons have
always been in favor of uh the
non-proliferation treaty mpt this goes
back to you know their formative years
in politics when bill was the
president of the united states india you
might recall did a surprise underground
test of nuclear weapons and clinton was
furious because he felt and made him
look bad and it was basically slapping
the face of the mpt treaty so he slapped
on heavy regulations and restrictions on
the export of u.s nuclear technology to
india whether it's for civilian purposes
or for nuclear purposes so and that's
pretty much the way that it remained
then in 2005 the bush administration
decided to do
or to consider nuclear cooperation
with the indian government they wanted
india to become more pro-american and
they said maybe we should share nuclear
technology but this would require a
change in the law by congress
and i recount this in the book i mean
indian officials are very sort of open
about this they quickly identified that
on the democrat side the person they
needed to target was hillary clinton she
was a powerful member of the senate
armed services committee a lot of people
look for her leadership on these issues
so guess what happened
you had indian industrialists who had
never given to the clinton foundation
before started writing large checks
you had bill got some speaking gigs from
indian entities
and there were really two people that
were involved in this one of them is an
indian politician who
has been accused of bribery and charged
with bribery numerous times named omar
singh
now armar singh met bill clinton in 2005
right when this was going on and if you
go to the clinton foundation disclosures
of their contributors
which they were required to do by
president obama by the way don't let
them convince you they did that
voluntarily it was a condition of her
being appointed secretary of state
president obama in his wisdom said you
need to disclose all your contributors
well one of the contributors they
disclosed is a guy named omar singh
and they disclosed him as a contributor
of between one and five million dollars
well you call up omar singh
and he said i didn't make that
contribution
and when you look at his financial
disclosures in the indian parliament
that that's more than his entire net
worth
so the question becomes who actually
made that contribution from omar singh
now omar singh came back later and said
well you know maybe that contribution
was made in my name by somebody else
but omar singh in 2008 when there was a
crucial vote coming up on the indian
nuclear deal which hillary clinton had
opposed he got a two-hour meeting with
hillary clinton hillary clinton came out
in favor
of the nuclear technology going to india
and much like the russia example you
know everybody was better off except
arguably the united states because we
got bad leadership the clintons got lots
of money in the form of speaking fees
and donations to the foundation a
foreign entity in this case the indian
government got what they wanted and the
rest of us got very poor leadership by
the way uh one of the people involved in
this is a guy named sand chatwall who
was later convicted for making illegal
campaign contributions to the clintons
he actually after the indians got the
nuclear deal signed in the united states
visited his home country he had lived in
new york was a hotelier went back to
india where he received the largest
civilian uh the most substantial
civilian prize that the indian
government could could win
and you know what the press release said
the press release said he won that award
because he got hillary clinton to change
her mind
on this issue
so that that is how it works and there
are numerous examples of her you know
changing her position after money showed
up
other questions
yes sir right there i think there's a
microphone right behind you
and then we'll go right here i
just like to know if you think there is
any chance of changing the status quo
with a donald trump or a ted cruz in
office cruz talking about the washington
cartel
uh trump of course just talking about
the establishment um and any prospects
of
reform
uh that's a good question you know look
one thing you can say about ted cruz and
donald trump is there a lot of people in
washington dc that don't like them
that could be for different reasons i
think with cruz you've got somebody who
has got
some pretty strong philosophical views
that he has expressed
with trump it's it's uh it's maybe less
philosophical it's more
visceral or emotive but what i find is
that if you look at basically
the four candidates that are less left
god bless john kasich but i don't view
him as being left in the in the mix of
things three of them are
anti-establishment
you've got ted cruz you've got donald
trump and then you've got bernie sanders
and you know people say to me um you
know well you know bernie sanders is for
big government and yes he is but he's
also anti-establishment i mean many of
the things we talk about um you know the
the crony capitalism are things that
that bernie sanders has been critical of
now his solutions are all wrong uh
because his solution is more government
which i argue would lead to more
cronyism but three of the four remaining
candidates are anti-establishment and i
think that says something um so yes i am
optimistic in the business that i'm in
you have to be an optimist by nature
because otherwise you would not get out
of bed in the morning
so yes i am optimistic all right uh this
will be the last question of the session
okay yeah that sounds great okay i'm
julie again
in in a in a broad sense this is not the
first time in history that we've seen
what uh has come to be called the
nomenclatures taking advantage of or
victimizing the subject
and the last memorable time this led
directly to la bastille
so do you think that we are on our way
to la bastille and how far are we if we
are
that's a very good question look i think
what you're seeing right now is uh
people expressing their anger and their
frustration with what's gone in
washington dc we were having a
conversation at lunch um very enjoyable
conversation and i gave people my theory
of donald trump's rise a lot of people
said they didn't see it coming they you
know some people are like i don't
understand his appeal
and you know here's my theory my theory
anybody out here a clint eastwood fan
okay i love clint eastwood great movie
fistful of dollars it's one of the old
italian spaghetti westerns
fistful of dollars is basically about a
small town that has had a succession of
sheriffs who just you know completely
get beat out by this gang and this gang
dominates this town so what does the
town do they decide to find the nastiest
surliest gunfighter clint eastwood and
pay him a lot of money to clean up the
town and and the guy does he comes in
and he basically shoots all the bad guys
shoots at the town and wins
my contention is a lot of of a lot of
trump supporters are hoping that donald
trump is clint eastwood in other words
they sent people to washington dc
they've they've sent people to
washington dc um who are these hapless
sheriffs who may be well intentioned and
are not corrupt but they just don't get
the job done
so let's bring in a guy uh to do the job
now anytime somebody tells a member of
the town that the clint eastwood
character is bad and nasty and terrible
they have no problem with that
right
he's got a very precise job to do and
you find the same thing you find the
same thing among trump supporters i mean
i you know i personally am not a trump
supporter but you know i would certainly
vote for him in a general election but
you know you go to people who aren't
trump supporters and i'd say oh you know
he said this and he said that doesn't
that bother you and they'd be like
not really
we need somebody like that to go and
clean up washington so um i think there
is an attitude and a mood in the country
uh that may not be quite at storming the
barricades uh but it's pretty bad i mean
75 of the american people believe that
washington dc is there's rampant
corruption 75 believe that the federal
government in some way represents a
threat to them these are not good
numbers
uh and the question becomes you know
where does it all lead i ultimately have
a lot of faith in the american people
i do not believe we're at a point where
uh you know things cannot be turned
around but the question becomes are
people a gonna be focused
you know are they gonna care and number
two are they gonna focus and channel uh
their frustration and anger in a
constructive way and and and time will
tell so again i'm optimistic on these
accounts but what i see swirling around
on both sides of the aisle republicans
and democrats is business at usual is no
longer acceptable and part of the reason
is because there's so much darn
corruption and you look at the two polar
opposites donald trump and bernie
sanders what is the thing that people
say about donald trump he's too rich to
be bought
now you can argue whether that's true or
not but part of the appeal is that he
cannot be corrupted and you will hear
people on the left say the same thing
about bernie sanders i may not agree
with bernie on everything but i don't
think bernie can be bought so we are at
a point in the country where there is uh
you know critical interest in this and i
just hope that there are enough people
in washington that take this opportunity
to do something constructive with it and
to make meaningful change thank you very
much i appreciate it